in the last video we started with
hydrogen bromide and pent-1-in and we
reasoned through a reaction mechanism
we'd say we said all right bromine is
much more electronegative than hydrogen
there's a partial negative charge but
maybe it takes maybe it takes hydrogen's
electron altogether so if we drew the
valence electron that the valence
electrons that bromine already had so it
would already have seven
valence electrons and this is the
seventh right there one two three four
five six seven and let me draw that
seventh one i'll do that seventh with an
orange as well but maybe hydrogen's
electron i'll draw in this yellow color
maybe that bond is yellow right there
now bromine would hog that electron so
we could literally show it as just
taking that electron and after it's
taken taken that electron we drew one
possible path where the bromine now has
eight valence electrons it has a
negative charge this yellow one is the
one it took from hydrogen hydrogen now
has a positive charge and in the next
step hydrogen took an electron from this
right carbon the carbon that was in the
carbon-carbon double bond it decided to
take it from this right carbon this one
of the pi bond between the two carbons
was broken now that was i won't call it
an arbitrary decision we'll see that
that's actually the more likely thing to
happen but it could have it would have
been possible maybe for it to take an
electron from the left carbon so let's
see what we would have ended up with if
that happened so let me draw let me draw
my pent-1 ain again so we have a
hydrogen
bonded to a carbon to a hydrogen we have
our double bond
bonded to a hydrogen
and then a ch2
ch2
ch3
and then we have our bromine
we have our bromine so let me draw that
right here so we have our
we draw it right
right over here
and
let me draw its eight valence electrons
i'll keep one in yellow just so we
remember that that actually originally
came from the hydrogen it was stripped
off its electron and it has a negative
charge it has a negative charge and then
we have the hydrogen which is really
just a proton now it has a positive
charge it has no electrons now instead
of this guy giving up his electron as we
saw in the last video let's make this
guy give up its allah his electron so
this pi bond right here this bond right
there
that this the left carbon will lose its
electron and it will go
it will
go to the hydrogen so we're doing kind
of the opposite of what happened right
there now if we go down that path what
is it going to look like
if we go down that path we'll show them
in parallel here so if we go down that
path
we have we now have our bromine hanging
out here let me copy and paste that
copy and
paste
so we have our bromine hanging out here
and now what does this molecule look
like it is no longer pent one in it now
has bonded with this hydrogen so let me
draw it out
so we have let me scroll down a little
bit
we have our a hydrogen
a carbon
a hydrogen
a single bond now to this carbon we have
one bond to a hydrogen
the bond to the rest of that business
over here ch2
ch2ch3 now this carbon is now bonded to
that hydrogen i'll do it in blue so this
carbon is now bonded to this hydrogen
this hydrogen is now neutral because it
has an electron you could view it as it
took it away from this carbon this
carbon now only has three valence
electrons or you could view it as only
it has five total electrons now it'll
have two in its lower shell
so it now has a positive charge it has
more protons than electrons so this
carbon right now has a positive charge
notice when we did in the last one the
carbon on the right had the positive
charge now the carbon on the left has
the positive charge and now in this
circumstance in this circumstance the
bromide ion will wanted to give an
electron or form a bond with this carbon
so let's draw that so bromine we could
just pick an arbitrary electron here
we'll form a bond to that carbon and
we're going to end up with something
slightly different than this it will
look like this so we have our
we have our maybe should i let me redraw
the whole thing so we have a carbon
bonded to a hydrogen
let me make it a little bit
cleaner
bonded to a hydrogen bonded to another
hydrogen bonded to a carbon which is
binding to a hydrogen
and then all of this
all of that right there this carbon on
the right is bonded to the hydrogen its
bond was blue just to remember allow us
to remember where things came from and
now this guy we could imagine forming a
green bond the color is more just to
show us what happened a green bond with
the bromide
so it forms a green bond with the brom
with the bromine it's no longer an ion
now it gave you could view it as it have
having it has given away an electron to
this carbon so now everyone is neutral
again now in this when we did the first
mechanism this thing that we got this
was
2-bromopentane where the bromo group is
on the or the bromel group is on the
second carbon when you number from the
left now we have one bromopentane so
this is a different molecule and both of
them seemed like reasonable mechanisms
now if you were to do this
experimentally if you were to take
hydrogen bromide and add it to your
pent-1-in like we saw you'll actually
find out that 95 of the product that 95
percent of what you produce will be the
two bromo
that the two bromo or maybe i don't want
to get specific with the numbers the the
great majority the great majority
the great majority that 95 percent
number actually was not for pent one in
that was actually for uh that was
actually for a hex1e so i don't want to
state that number but the great majority
of your product is going to be the
2-bromopentane and the minority of your
product is going to be the
1-bromopentane so this is the minority
so the first mechanism we showed is
actually the one that is more likely to
happen so the question is why was it
more likely to happen and i'll show you
a rule called markovnikov's rule that
tells you that at least allows you to
figure out which one is more likely and
then we can think a little bit about why
mark
markovnikov's rule holds
so markovnikov's rule let me write it
down markovnikov
markovnik
rule
is that the the carbon that already has
more hydrogens bonded to it is more
likely to bond to another hydrogen so
that's what happened in this left case
the carbon on the left already has it
has two hydrogens bonded to it the
carbon on the right only has one
hydrogen bonded to it so
markovnikov's rule says and he observed
this experimentally in the mid eighteen
hundreds he said okay the one that has
more hydrogens wants and more hydrogens
than it already has so it would tell us
that this circumstance is more likely
than that that this carbon is more
likely to bond to this hydrogen over
here as we saw in our first mechanism
than the right carbon bonding to the
hydrogen and that's because this left
carbon already was bonded to two
hydrogens this right carbon was only
bonded to one hydrogen so this one right
here is more
more
likely
and an easy way to remember it is is
that the one that's already bonded to
hot more hydrogens wants more hydrogens
and that eventually the one that's
bonded to more functional groups so
things other than hydrogen is more
likely to want to be bonded to other
functional groups or other things that
aren't hydrogen so if you were to just
look at this reaction here and you said
okay the hydrogen's going to bond to one
of these these carbons the bromine is
going to bond to the other you'd say
well look this carbon already has more
hydrogens bonded to it so it is more
likely to get the hydrogen and this
carbon has more functional groups it
actually has one functional group
attached to it right there so it is more
likely to attach to the bromine and we
see that there that's this is the
product that if you experimentally were
to do it you would have a majority of
now the one thing to think about why
that happens the reason why it happens
is that this so in either situation we
end up with a positive carbon and this
is called a carbon cation let me draw it
so this right here that carbon right
there is a carbocation the one that lost
the one that lost its electron that is a
carbo
carbocation in this example it was the
carbon on the left that lost its
electron that is also
that is also a carbon cation now
depending on how many carbons a or or
really you could view it as uh on how
many electron giving atoms a carbo
cation is bonded to that determines how
stable it is so there's one on the left
right here it is bonded to two carbons
and carbons are more likely to kind of
help out you're like oh you lost an
electron i got a lot of electrons let me
help you out let me share the pain with
you it is more stable when you're bonded
to more electron
giving electron giving atoms and in this
case you would call this a secondary
carbocation so this one right here is a
secondary
this is a secondary carbocation because
it is bonded to
two it is bonded to two carbons this one
right here is a primary
it is a primary carbocation because it
is only bonded to one carbon now what's
actually happening here the reason why
why markovnikov's rule hold he didn't
know why it worked he just observed it
but the reason why this is more likely
to happen than this on the right is
because a secondary carbocation is more
stable as is at a lower energy level
than a primary carbocation and that's
because it has more friends more carbon
friends that are willing to let it lend
it some electrons a primary carbocation
it was already hugging electrons from
hydrogens hydrogen does not have any
more electrons to lend or to
let kind of flow in that direction and
so he's not going to be as stable this
guy is and that's the reason why
markovnikov's rule holds secondary
carbocation is more stable than a
primary and if this was between a
secondary and a and a tertiary
carbocation one that actually has three
carbons attached to it the tertiary
one would be more stable so the more
carbons you're attached to or the more
electron giving atoms you're attached to
the more likely
the more stable you will be than other
people at giving away your electron